hi everyone in this video we are going
to show you how a locksmith is coding a
new key fob actually two of them for
2009 Infiniti G37
you will also see the key slot which is
where you have to put the key to program
new Keys new key fobs to start the
vehicle and
where you should put the key fob in case
the battery died
uh so you can start the vehicle with a
dead key fob please like this video and
comment below if you have any questions
hello everybody we're working on a
2009 uh Infiniti G37 we are going to add
a key into the system pretty much we
have to reprogram the key so
programming or adding keys for Nissan
Infinities all the same because
um you have to do the same procedure
so we're going to go to G37 sedan
let the machine read the car's
information
foreign
hooked up into the vehicle's OBD right
there
hazard lights are on
and the older Nissan Infinities they all
have slots so we're going to insert this
into the slots
and we're going to go to Smart Key
learning
it's telling us that all keys will be
erased
insert intelligent key into the slots
and turn the ignition on
power
it's communicating right now
so we will need to turn it off and back
on for the programming to go through
and here is the security light indicator
telling us that it's going well so we're
going to turn it off and then insert all
the keys that we need to program
into the system
here let's blinking again which is a
good sign
and we have one more key
a total of three keys to add on
and we are complete once we're done
check out the key and put in the first
key
close out the programming procedure
and the light is off meaning everything
is good
we are complete
test them out
this one probably has a dead battery
there's the original key
all right we're good let's start up